madeleine renaud est morte aujourd'hui
elle avait 94 ans elle disparaît huit
mois après jean louis barrault la fin
des journées parlementaires du rpr à
colmar il a répondu d'or balladur ce
matin après l'offensive de jacques
chirac le démantèlement d'un trafic de
faux billets de 500 francs dans le nord
la mobilisation d'un village de la drôme
mais en faveur d'une famille algérienne
très bien intégrés et qui est menacé
d'expulsion
et puis nous aurons l'immense plaisir à
la fin de ce journal de recevoir un à
romy campbell jusqu'ici mannequin
vedette et désormais chanteuse avec un
premier album qui sort aujourd'hui
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est donc par
sa voix et par son regard que nous
commencerons cette édition madeleine
renaud est parti aujourd'hui rejoindre
jean-louis barrault elle avait 94 10
pour les oreilles la peinture pour les
yeux
la gastronomie pour la langue peut rien
pour les narines
j'ai voulu réagir pour faire une petite
orgie d'odeur j'ai commencé par le plus
facile vieux livres herbes coupées
rosbif petit à petit je suis arrivé à
une soirée chez maxim une cour de ferme
au mexique a un que vous aimerez paul
noël à new york
salir espéré bien fort un prêt
alors qu'est ce que vous sentez le métro
extrait d'harold et mode au début d'un
livre qu'il avait écrit en 1950 jean
louis barrault avait repris cette phrase
de saint jean de la croix
au soir de cette vie vous serez jugés
sur l'amour madeleine renaud et jean
louis barrault étaient indissociables et
raconter la vie de l'un c'est un peu se
souvenir de l'autre françoise david
malgré ses apparences madeleine est une
artiste angoissé et qui souffre beaucoup
répétition alors comme nous nous
connaissons bien
je souffre doublement de la voir
souffrir comme elle voit que je souffre
de ce qu elle souffre elle souffre
triplement à part ça j'ai très agréable
plus répéter anciens un poème de jean
rostand récité devant une gloire d'alors
de la comédie française
la vie de cette toute jeune adolescente
était tracée elle serait comédienne
parcours classique le conservatoire et
la maison de molière
sa mère ne voulait pas qu'elle traverse
la scène pour rejoindre l'odéon marié
achard le grand val également comédien
elle vit bourgeoisement avant de
rencontrer en 1936 l'homme qui va
bouleverser son existence
jean louis barrault amour tout court
amour de la vie amour du théâtre un
couple mythique aîné
j'ai reçu une lettre de mancy dans
laquelle ils me disaient nous avons
beaucoup parlé poids avec mon père nous
avons compris que l'homme qui était fait
pour te rendre heureuse était jean-louis
alors nous te donnons la permission de
mariée en 1946 il décide de voler de
leurs propres ailes
la compagnie renaud barrault est né l
emportera dans le monde entier rabelais
molière voltaire tchekhov giraudoux
claudel ionesco duras beckett beckett
dont madeleine renaud jours à tenter
tant de fois au les beaux jours pour
jours encore pour moi ce oreilles
être comédien c'est s'ouvrir
complètement stérilisées le personnage
qu'on va interpréter en dedans de vous
alors à partir de ce moment-là nous
comme ils viennent n'existant plus et
c'est le personnage qui nous dicte ses
sensations et c'est ce qu'il veut nous
dire vous mettez vos de quoi comme ça
nous touche mais placé sous l'extrémité
de la langue
oui c'est la langue en arrière jusqu'à
ce que les lèvres toucha première
phalange 1re classe fermée l'élève et
puis vous soufflez des salles de vue et
des ovations interminable madeleine et
jean louis en avait connu ensemble des
milliers ce jour là toujours ensemble il
avait salué pour la dernière fois leurs
camarades de théâtre de très nombreuses
réactions de très nombreux témoignages
d'admiration d'affection madeleine
renaud était né avec le siècle en 1901
siècle qu'elle aura traversé pour
devenir une véritable légende de notre
théâtre réactions recueillies par
thiriez
madame reno était une personne une femme
absolument exquise qu'on avait envie de
prendre cinq ans ses bras avec qui on
avait envie d'être tendre et c'est pour
ça aussi que moi je suis très serein
c'est fou ce qu'elle a joué dans savez
quand on y pense elle l a été l a été
des plus grandes sociétaire de la
comédie française et après elle est
devenue une avait avec jean louis
barrault des plus grandes animatrices du
théâtre moderne et alors elle est passée
quand même d'un répertoire qui n'était
absolument pas le sien habituellement un
autre au répertoire par jean louis et
toujours la même théorie
pour moi c'est une fable de la fontaine
à dire elle ne compliqué jamais les
choses et au fond elle jouait avec son
coeur elle représentait la vérité
l'authenticité quand on la voyait sur
scène on se disait ce que cette femme là
des c'est vrai
elle était très solide ma petite
madeleine très solide et très courageuse
aussi car je les ai vus jouer moi
santiago du chili avec un phlegmon
il le fief de cheval elle jouait comme
si de rien n'était quand on partait
depuis trois-quatre fois comme ça elle
me elle me disait ah moi elle me disait
tu te rappelles et de coire avec sa voix
de jeune fille reste de vous de la nuit
les obsèques de madame reno se
dérouleront mardi matin à paris à noter
que notre chaîne lui rendra un hommage
la veille lundi soir un premier hommage
avec un cercle de minuit spécial
madeleine renaud et puis jeudi soir avec
le film de jean grémillon le ciel étape
pour pour suivre l'actualité nous
quittons le rêve la poésie et le théâtre
pour nous retrouver dans l'atmosphère
polluée de paris si la pollution à
dépasser cet été la côte d' alerte et
selon un rapport de l'observatoire
régional de la santé qui vient d'être
publié les hospitalisations et même les
décès ont considérablement augmenté dans
cette période
en quête de josé blanc la pierre et jean
daniel flaysakier la pollution
parisienne serait plus dangereuse qu'on
ne le croit elle provoquerait au moment
des pointes une augmentation de 10 à 20%
des cas d'hospitalisation
pire elle entraînerait le décès des
personnes fragiles atteintes de maladies
cardiovasculaires ou respiratoires
d'important on chiffre l'excès de cette
mortalité aux alentours de 6% premiers à
constater les effets de la pollution
les médecins essentiellement donc
gueddas donc des compensations crises
d'asthme avec toute la gravité que ça
peut entraîner surtout sur des personnes
âgées ou fragilisées
autrement une pathologie aux horaires
essentiellement sinusite rhume
manifestations allergiques respiratoires
une augmentation
significatif mais à fait minime de
l'ordre de 10 à 15 5 pour une pathologie
habituel des médecins ont observé et
consignés dans un rapport les effets de
la pollution parisienne de 1987 à 92 ce
rapport est toujours secrets je trouve
le silence de la mairie de paris
très étonnant sur cette question qui est
quelque chose de grave en termes de
santé publique
mais force est de constater
qu'actuellement la politique est encore
à la priorité à la voiture à paris
faut-il alors limiter le nombre de
voitures dans la capitale rappelons que
cet été la côte d'alerté a été dépassé
au moins cette fois ci la pollution est
aussi grave qu'on le dit les pouvoirs
publics devront trouver des solutions
faute de quoi les parisiens devront
imiter les japonais et sortir masqué
dans le nord maintenant un réseau très
important de faux monnayeurs qui
fabriquait des billets de 500 francs
presque plus vrai que nature vient
d'être démantelé près de lille l'enquète
de benoît gadret et gilles balbastre
voici quelques spécimens des six mille
faux billets de 500 francs soit une
somme totale de 3 millions de nouveaux
francs saisis mercredi par la police
un vrai travail de professionnels de
l'impression comme l'expliquent cet
enquêteur
c'est une excellente contrefaçon qui
était paru il ya quelques mois en effet
d'une part alain très bon sonnant vous
pouvez le constater également elle ne
répond pas
une ampoule fluorescente ce qui lui
permet d'être
non détectable dans les appareils en
revanche le filigrane l'idée très
mauvaise qualité
ces faux billets ont été découverts à
harnes dans le pas de calais chez un
individu considéré par la police comme
un grossiste six autres personnes dont
certaines fichés au grand banditisme ont
été interpellés dans le nord ces billets
étaient écoulés dans la région de roi ou
le srpj locale a arrêté une quinzaine de
distributeurs le trafic de fausse
monnaie ressemble étrangement au trafic
de stupéfiants
l'anc est coordonné par un juge de
bobigny pourrait conduire les policiers
dans d'autres régions de france c'est
faux billets imprimés et non photocopier
étaient revendus aux distributeurs
entre 70 et 200 francs pièce
quinze jours après le terrible carnage
de thorigné sur dué dans la sarthe une
reconstitution a eu lieu la nuit
dernière dany leprince est revenu dans
le pavillon où il aurait tué son frère
sa belle soeur et ses deux nièces une
reconstitution qui n'a apporté que des
réponses incomplètes aux interrogations
des enquêteurs
thiery kurt et et frédéric faure la nuit
qui s'avance recréer les mêmes
conditions que la soirée tragique du 4
septembre le juge brunetière est arrivé
il est un peu plus de 20 heures
la reconstitution va pouvoir commencer
dany leprince a été amené dans une
voiture de gendarmerie caché sous une
couverture
s'il a avoué le meurtre de son frère il
n'a pas reconnu avoir tué sa belle soeur
ni ses deux nièces de six et dix ans
dany ici à droite était tenue n'a pas
précisé s'il avait transporté le corps
de son frère ni si quelqu'un d'autre que
lui avait passé des traces qu'il a pu
laisser des questions qui n'ont sans
doute pas eu toute une réponse lire ou
soir
car si à l'extérieur dany a accepté de
refaire les gestes meurtriers avec son
hachoir
il a refusé de répondre aux questions
des magistrats à l'intérieur de la
maison
une reconstitution sous haute
surveillance
quatre-vingts gendarmes avaient bouclé
le secteur très tôt dans la journée
rien ne devait gêner le bon déroulement
de cette soirée temps le fils qui mène à
la vérité semble ténue si malgré tout
l'anc est avancé hier il semble
aujourd'hui probable qu'il y aura
d'autres reconstitution pour déterminer
quel a été le rôle exact de l'entourage
de dany cette nuit du 4 septembre
l'ancien maire de nice le sénateur rpr
on aurait bel et bien d'être mise en
examen la justice lui reproche ainsi
qu'à sa femme de s'être fait offrir des
voyages par la sers elle une entreprise
niçoise en échange l'ancien maire de
nice aurait permis à la serre elles
d'obtenir des marchés publics
et puis dans la sphère de la villa de
gérard longuet à saint tropez le
ministre de la justice pierre
méhaignerie décidera dans les jours qui
viennent s'il demande l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire à colmar la
deuxième journée des parlementaires du
rpr a été la journée balladur le premier
ministre a répondu à l'offensive de
jacques chirac hier en distribuant à son
tour quelques coups de griffes et en
revendiquant bien sûr sans le dire
vraiment le statut de candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
véronique saint-olivier pierre
moscovitch jacques chirac et edouard
balladur ont choisi de s'affronter pour
la première fois en public devant les
parlementaires rpr devant leur famille
une famille que déjà il s'arrache notre
force
le chef compagnon c'est l'unité de notre
mouvement mais c'est surtout pour demain
la pérennité de notre famille et le
danger pour nous ce n'est pas tant la
dit
c'est la dilution ce qui fait une
famille politique forte au delà des
convictions partagées
c'est aussi le succès la dernière fois
qu'un gaulliste a été élu président de
la république c'était georges pompidou
c'était en 1969 c'était il ya un quart
de siècle
depuis pour des raisons diverses
ça n'a pas été possible et toc
le président du rpr évoque alors la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale si
edouard balladur était élu mais aussitôt
le premier ministre ratio les trous et
rappelle qu'il a engagé des réformes sur
cinq ans point par point ils se
renvoient la balle
le premier ministre a l'avantagé de
parler le dernier alors il prend de la
hauteur compagnon c'est cela qu'il va
s'agir de notre capacité à nous adresser
à tous les français cette capacité
nous l'avons j'en suis sûr et nous
serons là témoigner edouard balladur
revendique son bilan à matignon pour
justifier en quelque sorte son projet à
l'elysée
il entre donc ouvertement dans le débat
présidentiel et au terme de cette
première passe d'armes à colmar avec
jacques chirac le premier ministre
prouve aussi qu'il ne fera aucun cadeau
au président du rpr entre celui que
beaucoup considèrent au rpr comme le
candidat naturel et jacques chirac et
celui qui est pour l'instant le mieux
placé pour l'emporter edouard balladur
les 260 députés rpr devront bien un jour
choisir un choix cornélien auquel est
confronté par exemple antoine joly
députée de la sarthe qu'on rencontrait
jérôme cathala et alain rap chaud et
adam a priori il n'en a pas l'air mais
cet homme est bel bien déchirer en fait
antoine joly et même un cas d'école en
mars 93 il est élu député rpr de la
sarthe pour la première fois aujourd'hui
il a un peu de mal à comprendre pourquoi
le mouvement gaulliste n'affiche plus la
belle unité d'alors
moi je me souviens par exemple de mon
journal électoral où j'avais un mot de
balladur et puis j'étais en photo avec
chirac
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là il était
clair que balladur à l'aide premier
ministre puis jacques chirac se
préparait pour les présidentielles et
donc les militants comme les élus
étaient partis sur cette hypothèse et
puis ensuite le député de
circonscription de suisse est plongé
dans sa conception
et puis on se réveille quelques mois
plus tard effectivement avec ce dilemme
qui petit à petit a grossi alors
chiraquien ou balladuriens cette
question les militants rpr de la sarthe
la pose de plus en plus souvent à
antoine joly lui préfère attendre et
voir
et ici à colmar lors des journées
parlementaires du mouvement gaulliste il
a vu mais n'arrivent toujours pas à se
déterminer ce qu'on souhaiterait quand
même c'est qu'effectivement ces deux
candidats une fois ce débat passer
effectivement ensuite en homme d'état se
déterminer que nous ayons effectivement
une union à la présidentielle ce serait
mieux
bref pour antoine joly comme pour
d'autres le mieux serait de ne pas avoir
à choisir entre l'un ou l'autre car
quand on a 39 ans et l' envie de faire
carrière en politique on n'a pas très
envie de se brouiller avec un candidat
même potentiel à l'elysée dernier mot
concernant la présidentielle valéry
giscard d'estaing n'exclut pas la
présence dans la course à l'elysée d'un
candidat de l'udf un grand parti comme
edf sans candidat présidentiel n'a pas
de raison d'être dit il dans un
entretien au quotidien la montagne qui
sera publié demain à rome maintenant de
multiples interrogations autour de la
santé de jean paul ii un mois al avance
son voyage prévu à new york a été annulé
le pape dont les activités seraient de
plus en plus réduites au vatican notre
correspondant à l'un d'eux seuls c'était
début juin jean paul ii recevait bill
clinton
le pape sortait de l'hôpital où il avait
été opéré le 29 avril du col du fémur il
semblait bien
ne cédez pas d'une canne s'asseyait sans
aide et son visage par et ses soeurs
août le pape est en vacances au val
d'aoste
ils marchent maintenant avec une canne a
du mal à monter dans son hélicoptère et
son visage est marqué par la douleur 10
septembre voyage officiel à zagreb
le monde entier est frappé par ces
images du pape qui a de plus en plus de
mal à marcher ne peut plus s'agenouiller
pour embrasser le sol et souffre
visiblement de plus en plus
mercredi dernier audiences publiques au
vatican nouvelle dégradation dégradation
confirmé le lendemain en quelque sorte
par cette annulation de ce voyage à new
york
officiellement selon le vatican le pape
ne souffre que des suites de son
opération du col du fémur il a 74 ans et
marque le coup il a besoin de se reposer
de reprendre ces séances de rééducation
la presse italienne se demande pourtant
quel est ce mal qui bloque le pape
certains parlent d'une maladie de
parkinson d'autres d'un cancer des os
d'autres une tumeur aux intestins autant
de rumeurs que rien ne vient corroborer
rien sinon les images les pays bas
auront tout tenté pour essayer de sauver
un de leurs ressortissants condamnés à
mort à singapour pour trafic de drogue
des centaines de pétitions une
intervention de la reine n'y auront rien
fait johan van damme a été pendu ce
matin les réactions amsterdam avec nos
envoyés spéciaux vincent nguyen et
raymond chaplin johannes van damme avait
59 ans il ya trois ans alors qu'il
rentrait de thaïlande
il a été arrêté à l'aéroport de
singapour avec quatre kilos 32 d'héroïne
dissimulée dans le double fond de sa
valise le 26 mai 93
après des mois de prison et un procès de
3 semaines il a été condamné à mort
alors qu'il n'avait cessé de clamer son
innocence
la valise lui auraient été confiées par
un ingénieur nigérian la diplomatie
hollandaise avait tenté de négocier avec
singapour en vain la reine béatrice
elle-même s'était ému du sort de
johannes van damme malgré lé recours en
grâce déposée hier par son avocat il a
été pendu cette nuit ce matin la presse
allait réserver ses gros titres à la
faire dans la rue chacun avait son mot à
dire
il savait ce qu'on fait dans ce pays il
vous pend dont elles mettent en prison
il connaissait les risques et il les a
pris alors mais la plupart des
hollandais sont tout de même choqué
qu'il ait fait ça ne fait rien me tuer
c'est très dur c'est choquant d'halong
qui tu es français
chez les quads bien sûr il aurait dû le
punir c'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais le
pendre c'est un peu un cachot younes
vandal est le premier européen exécuté à
singapour depuis l'instauration de la
loi anti drogue en 1975
ici en hollande elle l'a laissé personne
indifférent il faut dire que l'appel
ici est abolie depuis 1870 à moscou
maintenant la russie a été privé de
défense stratégique pendant quelques
minutes il hier une histoire à peine
croyable
l'électricité a été coupée dans le
centre où sont entreposés les missiles
nucléaires censés défendre le pays
tout simplement parce que la facture
n'avait pas été réglé les ordres sont
les ordres à moscou dominique d'erding
jean-françois bernier au ministère de la
défense ce matin on était plutôt furieux
et les officiers d'habitude si réservé
n'y allait pas par quatre chemins il
faut mettre de l'ordre dit ce général il
faut virer ces irresponsables sur le
champ les militaires en effet ont de
quoi être pour le moins mécontent car
l'histoire n'est pas banale
mercredi à une dizaine de kilomètres à
l'ouest de moscou le centre de commande
des missiles stratégiques reçoit un coup
de téléphone des services de
l'électricité puisque vous n'avez pas
payer vos factures dit l'employé de la
compagnie et bien vous êtes prévenus on
va vous couper le courant panique au
quartier général il faut d'urgence
branché d'alimentation de secours sinon
c'est la catastrophe
voilà ce qui aurait bien fait rire mais
heureusement le groupe électrogène a
bien fonctionné il faudra une heure et
quart avant que l'état major ne
parviennent à faire rétablir
l'alimentation générale à moscou la
ferté plus de bruit que le plus gros des
missiles on a osé traiter comme un
vulgaire mauvais payeurs l'un des
maillons essentiels du système de
défense
victor tchernomirdine le premier
ministre est fou de rage il promet que
très vite
des têtes vont tomber à la compagnie
d'électricité on tente de se justifier
et l'on rappelle que le centre de
commande des missiles stratégiques à une
ardoise de quelque trois millions et
demi de francs depuis janvier dernier si
ça continue comme ça on aura bientôt le
choix entre alimenté soit les usines et
les centres industriels soit les
immeubles d'habitation les écoles les
crèches les hôpitaux et je crois bien
alors ce sont les gens que nous
choisirons ainsi donc en russie pour
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
il faut parfois commencé par couper le
courant
il n'y a pas que le ministère de la
défense qui est des fins de mois
difficiles le phénomène en fait touche
tous les secteurs de l'économie russe et
c'est le plus souvent l'état qui d'un
côté prône des réformes prône
l'instauration de l'économie de marché
et qui de l'autre a bien du mal à payer
ses factures dernières informations
concernant l'étranger l'espagne a décidé
d'acheter 5 mirage f1 à la france un
contrat de 285 millions de francs voilà
qui renforcera la bonne santé de notre
commerce extérieur qui affiche pour le
mois de juillet un excédent de 5
milliards 725 millions de francs dans la
drôme les habitants d'un village se
mobilise en faveur d'une famille
algérienne une famille très bien intégré
mais à qui l'administration a refusé
l'asile politique et qui se retrouve
menacée d'expulsion le reportage à
pierre longue de yannick aroussi et
jean-françois giorgetti des rues des
heures que sous une pluie battante
pauvre en monde aujourd'hui à pierre
longue la moitié des habitants se trouve
en effet à grenoble ils sont venus
soutenir au tribunal administratif la
famille sellami menacés d'expulsion
restés au village les adjoints au maire
recueille les messages de sympathie
tous les habitants se sont réunis hier
soir pour former un comité de soutien
aux seuls amis nous aurons tout pour la
famille sélam y reviennent ap irlande ou
en nous considérant qu'ils font partie
du village une famille avec quatre
enfants
mais abandonner comme ça
laissez-les amie habite ici depuis deux
ans ils ont quitté l'algérie par crainte
des intégristes du fils en situation
irrégulière nasser et sa femme vivent de
petits boulots ils sont appréciés des
villageois alors quand les gendarmes
sont venus les chercher au petit matin
personne n'a rien compris il y avait
beaucoup de gendarmes pour pour une
intervention qui ne méritait pas
il méritait pas ça le tribunal
administratif vient de rendre sa
décision
laissez-les amis pourront rester en
france jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve un pays
d'accueil mais ils devront de toute
façon quitter pire longue
le mini l'ouragan annoncé hier par météo
france c'est en fait transformé en
fortes pluies des pluies malheureusement
meurtrière un automobiliste s'est noyé
dans l'aveyron cet après midi et dans
l'hérault
la ville de lunel a été en grande partie
inondé michèle fines au village de lunel
entre nîmes et montpellier la pluie est
tombée sans s'arrêter 2010 jusqu'à 14
heures en deux heures une cinquantaine
de caves et des rez de chaussée a été
inondée à la fois quand on était venus
ici s'installer le maire de lunel nous
avait fait un serment au moment de
l'époque de vaison la romaine en nous
disant qu'ils auraient jamais d'eau ici
et puis on s'aperçoit qu'on âge dans 20
à 30 cm
les habitants en ont assez le maire ne
sait plus que faire les installations ne
suffisent plus à évacuer l'eau et des
quartiers entiers ont été construits en
zone inondable s'est alors servi de quoi
vous parlez il était et n'aura plus en
plus comme chaque fois lorsqu'il pleut
un peu fort les pompiers sont intervenus
et les habitants ont passé la journée à
faire évacuer l'eau demain ils se
réuniront pour essayer de trouver une
solution à cette situation que les
autorités n'arrivent plus à régler
et pour oublier un peu l'eau direction
les bistrots ils sont en fait jamais les
comptoirs en france n'ont été autant
fréquentée analyse sociologique au
gustatives d'un doublé ce qui est
françois g
blood of the shop l'animal adyal cette
e-menace bien sûr c'est du champagne
nous sommes dans un bistrot du quartier
des halles à paris les professionnels de
l'alimentation ont filé vers rungis
depuis longtemps eux sont restés là et
ils vivent bien
li en france 70 mille cafés bars tabacs
brasserie dont 10000 rien qu'à paris
tous les cinquante ans on annonce leur
mort en réalité il ne meurt pas il se
transforme le bistrot d'aujourd'hui
remplace le café d'après guerre il
évolue vers la restauration pour vivre
il fait la guerre aux faces le selon un
sondage bva seule la moitié des français
fréquentent les cafés l'autre moitié n'y
va jamais pour 80% des habitués c'est un
lieu des changes pour 46% un espace de
liberté
ici le patron fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour mériter cette réputation bon verre
ou manger un bon morceau est bien un
certain climat quand même une une amitié
ici c'est la famille réellement
mais si c'est la famille vous occupez
mois dans votre propre famille non alors
absolument forme ça arrive à voir
c'est le complément dion et jean se
côtoient comme s'ils connaissent depuis
20 ans c'est vrai que c'est pas le
problème de génération là il y en a pas
vous n'entrez on sort de mon ressort
différents latute c'est la tour on
ressort comme un autre c'est à dire
qu'on aurait aimé les femmes seules au
café sont elles allaient sont elles les
bienvenus aucune étude ne répond la
question le photographe robert doisneau
disait ou café les femmes font semblant
d'attendre quelqu'un est ce toujours
vrai aujourd'hui certainement beaucoup
moins
dernière surprise de la journée les
habitants de gonfreville l'orcher près
du havre se sont réveillés en plein
cauchemar ce matin de grosse météorite
venait de tomber en plein centre ville
ce cauchemar ce mystère méritait une
enquête parce qu'elle dit c'est bon et
jean-françois chevet il était 2 heures
la nuit dernière lorsque l' alerte a été
donnée à gonfreville
les agresseurs venaient du ciel de
météorites d'une tonne chacun ce matin
les gonfrevillais était encore sous le
choc
georges venu à bout mais je crois que
lorqu'il était au juste entendu quelque
chose soit 8000 cela au plus vite sa vie
malgré la peur le bilan est miraculeux
un seul blessé un homme de 44 ans qu'il
a fallu extirper de sa voiture ses jours
ne sont pas en danger mais alors
question comment de projectiles de cette
taille ont-ils pu arriver sans prévenir
ce qui n'est pas poli du tout chacun ici
à son opinion
même la vo est à l'étude dans ses
papiers tout à fait mais johnny qui a eu
un mystérieux id tuer mais doit signer
qu il y en a qui disent royaume uni soit
notre 9 x et du marais dans sa vie ils
n'ont pas 10 ans mais ce sont eux qui
ont raison point de météorites pas de
blessés mais du carton pâte et une mise
en scène qui a très bien marché
il s'agissait d'un coup de pub de la
mairie pour le lancement d'une
exposition dont s'excuse auprès de la
sécurité civile d'une telle réaction des
gens ça montre de le poids de
l'information quand même vous soyez
quand même vous êtes fiers de vous oh
pas dire fier le but est et aigaliers là
on parle de nous peut-être un peu trop
d'ailleurs
et monsieur l'adjoint peut s'excuser
parce que tous les pompiers de la région
ont été mises en alerte la sécurité
civile du havre n'a pas vraiment
apprécié ce canular un peu trop bien
monté l'année prochaine la mairie de
gonfreville pense faire venir des
martiens là encore ce sera drôlement
marrant
voilà après cette fausse alerte un vrai
plaisir celui de recevoir sur ce plateau
ce soir naomi cambell bonsoir merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints naomi
cambell tout le monde vous connaît pour
défilés de mannequins de mannequin
vedette depuis plusieurs années et puis
vous décidez de passer à la chanson avec
un premier album qui sort aujourd'hui
qui s'appelle femmes enfants pourquoi
pourquoi c'est pourquoi ce passage est
ce que vous changer de peau vous changer
de vie en fait tous cas remonte à
quelque chose que j'ai étudié c'est à
dire les arts du spectacle de la scène
tout cela je le fais de large et 5 ans
que je suis devenu modèle dont j'ai
arrêté maintenant en fait je reviens à
ce que j'avais l'intention de faire dès
le départ
voilà le voici oui si je peux me
permettre
est ce qu'il y à un âge où on se dit il
faut peut-être maintenant que je
commence à penser à autre chose non
installé à mais non pas vraiment il y a
des gens qui ont 51 ans
et qui sont encore modèles comme lauren
hutton par exemple moi je voulais
chanter maintenant je voulais être sur
scène c'est toujours ce que j'ai voulu
faire c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne la musique et je voulais m'y
impliquer beaucoup plus que je ne le
ferais donc maintenant je suis capable
de le faire alors l'album s'appelle
s'appelle femmes en france et c'est un
titre c'est un titre qui vous ressemble
je crois bien écoutez je crois que
beaucoup d'entre nous on passe d'un côté
enfin on nous mêmes et pas forcément
visuel d'ailleurs je crois que ça peut
s'exprimer de diverses façons en étant
créatif de diverses manières mais je
crois que c'est bien d'avoir ça on va
écouter l'extrait de la principale
chansons de cet album qui s'appelle love
and tears de l'amour et les larmes de
l'amour il est là un extrait d'une vidéo
clip
est-ce qu'il ya quand on évolue comme ça
dans sa carrière cette volonté peut-être
de présenter quelque chose qui soit un
peu plus personnel que simplement un
défilé dans un
dans une présentation de mode avec avec
ses chansons avec le livre que vous avez
inspiré récemment est ce qu'on découvre
une nouvelle non non non non il n'y a
pas de rapport en fait la musique c'est
ma priorité essentielle à l'heure
actuelle et c'est ça que je vais faire
je vais enregistrer faire de la musique
et lorsque je serai modèle j'en ai alors
un certain nombre de choses
ça m'a beaucoup plu l'industrie de la
mode m'a beaucoup aidé et m'a aidé
justement à faire cet album donc je ne
dirai jamais non à une offre si je peux
le faire je le ferai mais la vraie naomi
cambell et celle qui chantait qu'on va
peut-être découvrir un peu un peu mieux
un peu plus en profondeur que que sur un
défilé de mannequins
oui oui je le crois pas ce qu'on peut
s'exprimer et finalement se donner
donner des choses des sentiments des
sensations auquel les gens peuvent
s'identifier et je crois que leur
vennetier c'est justement des choses que
les gens peuvent ressentir un moment
donné dans leur vie donc s'identifier
avec ce que je dis est ce que vous avez
des idoles des modèles dans ce monde du
cinéma dans ce monde de la musique
oui absolument joséphine baker je sais
qu'en france tout le monde la connaît
mais en amérique ce n'est pas le cas
mongi britannique
mais c'est une grande idole pour moi
elle m'a toujours inspiré beaucoup de
femmes qui ont fait du cinéma de la
musique se sont engagés pour des causes
importantes nous parlons souvent ils
nous dans nos journaux de d'information
qui ne sont pas très gai on pense à
audrey hepburn qui s'est engagée jane
fonda également qui s'est engagé à
travers les nations unies est ce que
naomi cambell souhaitent ou s'est déjà
engagé pour pour des causes
internationales
j'ai déjà engagés dans un bon nombre de
causes internationales à
new york la coalition des vins noirs
également pour les enfants et voilà
également la maladie le sida j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont noirs ça veut
dire beaucoup pour moi c'est quelque
chose qui vous paraît important vous
aller vous allez faire de plus en plus
dans ce sens là ce que je ferai des
concerts j'aimerais bien donner une
certaine somme d'argent pour
véritablement aider des gens dans lequel
je le hais le dans certains pays comme
l'irlande justement les séropositifs
n'ont aucun soutien il n'a pas d'être
financière je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'endroits 8 fois les otages et moi je
suis donc engagé dans cette association
je suis heureuse que l'on me demandait
et lorsque j'ai l'occasion comme moi
aujourd'hui de le faire je crois qu'il
faut pour s'engager et aider les autres
un dernier mot naomi cambell le titre de
la chanson s'appelle love and tears de
l'amour et des larmes ça veut dire que
selon vous l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
mais quelqu'un parfois ça ne marche pas
se séparer
ça fait pleurer et pourtant on sait
qu'il faut faire il faut faire et puis
il peut y avoir également des l'ère des
larmes de joie c'est pas forcément des
larmes de tristesse
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
c'est un immense plaisir de vous
recevoir et bonne chance donc à la suite
de votre carrière et au disque qui sort
aujourd'hui
merci ne terminons ce journal par du
sport avec les essais du grand prix de
formule 1 du portugal qui se courra
dimanche un grand prix où l'on dit
toujours qu'il se passe chaque année
quelque chose et cela a commencé
aujourd'hui par un violent accrochage à
estoril lionel chamoulaud et jean
cordier la très grosse peur de damon
hill sa williams-renault est catapulté
par la jordan d'irvine à la dérive
ils s'envolent c'est spectaculaire et
heureusement ça se termine plutôt bien
j'ai vraiment pris le temps de
comprendre ce qui se passait je crois
qu'en fait j'ai raté un peu mon
l'atterrissage un peu d'humour
britannique et une ambiance moins
sereine chez benetton schumacher purge
son deuxième et dernier grand prix de
suspension et les taux et d'arte apple
ont bien du mal à se mêler à la bagarre
pour le meilleur temps aujourd'hui les
bénévoles ne sont que 10e et 11e
l'allemand semble manquer cruellement
je pense que mickaël trouvait très vite
les bonnes solutions sur la voiture
parce qu'il a une grande expérience il
avait tout de suite imposer les bons
réglages
il savait toujours quoi faire pour
gagner du temps à monza les bennes et n
était en milieu de grille ici elles sont
à deux secondes de la pole position à se
demander si seuls schumacher est capable
d'optimiser cette voiture spécialement
le vendredi donné les indications
allaient gêner maintenant elle avant de
dire on est toujours là les ailes et on
va me hollet normalement le samedi parce
que les deux jeunes il ya un pas c'était
facile avec une demi heure
or voilà que parfait celui qui est la
voiture parfaite aujourd'hui seeberger
sa ferrari précède la williams de damon
hill
jean alesi est 5e voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal dans un instant la météo avec
nathalie roux et de fortes pluies sont à
attendre cette nuit toujours dans le sud
est de la france et de mal se décaleront
à l'est du rhône le point route avec
valérie maurice puis à 20h55 les cinq
dernières minutes pierre santini
22h35 bouillon de culture bernard pivot
23h45 taratata
nagui reçoit ce soir jacques higelin
vers 1h le dernier journal vous est
présenté par antoine cormery à noter
demain matin de 11h à 12h la revue de
presse de michèle cotta et j'aurais
plaisir de vous retrouver à 13 eur puis
à 20 heures excellente soirée merci
beaucoup de votre attention
au revoir merci bail